Hey! Welcome to a new Project Kamp update!
In the previous video, you could see us building this new compost toilet.
But, one thing we didn't finish was the roof...
Because, we wanted to try something new and experimental,
which took a bit longer than expected.
So, in this video, we're going to use
old drinking cans to make a roof!
We're gonna collect five hundred of them.
We've already tried a few tests to see how we can make it work.
Because, it's kind of a new technique we're sort of trying to develop.
So, we're not sure how it's gonna go,
and if it's gonna be waterproof...
Let's find out.
The video itself is sponsored by Surfshark, an online VPN.
We use this advertisements to make sure we can fund our tractor.
But, more about that later!
Now, we are gonna start the week,
and the first we're gonna do is help the neighbor out to harvest some corn.
Let's go!
- So, we were asked by our dear friend and neighbor Jorge to go
up to his land and to help him picking some corn.
We were just about to leave the land right now!
- So, we're getting all this corn, stripping it down,
putting it in a bucket, and he is gonna use this.
They're gonna bring it to a mill, to mill it into flour to make bread.
Some of it is gonna go to his animals to feed them.
- Hello corn, my name is Ingrid!
Can I undress you?
Yes, you can!
- I have the red one!
- It represents for happiness in your marriage!
So, you kind of ruined it now by taking off the leaves...
Maybe.
How did you do it?
How did you get it on to the truck?
- Ok, ok. I'll help you.
Are we done now?
Done.
Lots of corn!
- What time? Snack time!
After the hard work, we had a snack from the neighbors,
typically called bucha.
They also let us pick up some fruit for the people at the Kamp.
So, we are done with the harvesting,
and we harvested ourselves a lot of things!
This is all the things we take back after harvesting some corn!
- Nice!
So, that was the corn picking for this year.
It's really nice to see the work land full of fruit trees from Jorge!
So much work went into this already!
It makes us realize we still have a lot of work ahead on our land...
We could really use a tractor to take on this bigger landwork...
To get that, we really need to talk about Surfshark.
It's a virtual private network, also called a VPN.
It allows you to browse on the Internet safely.
You can encrypt your data.
You can change your IP address,
so you can decide from which location you're browsing the Internet.
This is cool, because most of the people here come
from completely different countries around the world!
They can't always access the same content
as they can do back home.
So, for instance, I have a pretty cool documentary about
the early days of Project Kamp.
But, you can only watch it if you're in the Netherlands...
So, with a VPN, you could say:
"I'm watching this thing from the Netherlands!"
Even though you are in Portugal!
This also happens on other platforms, like for instance, Netflix.
If people here want a show or movie from their own country,
it's not always possible...
But then, with a VPN, they can go to their own country
and then they can watch it!
It can also be useful to provide an extra layer of privacy for sensitive information,
like card numbers, personal data or passwords.
If you work in a team and you need to share data a lot
with your colleagues, it's pretty nice to have it safe.
Especially if you're working remotely, connected to a sketchy public Wi-Fi.
Which we used to do a lot in the early days...
Overall, Surfshark is easy to use!
It accepts an unlimited amount of devices!
And, it's compatible with all operating systems!
So, its a useful tool, and we figured it might be useful for you as well.
If you use this code, you can get a discount
with three months extra for free!
The link is in the description below
You can just give it a try, because if you don't like it,
you get your thirty days money in return.
So what about the tractor?
Now, if you can do four advertisements like this, we can buy ourselves a tractor...
We already did one before!
Now, we did another one.
So, we have two more left.
If we manage to integrate this,
we can get a new tractor, which is very cool!
So, thank you guys very much for watching these videos!
It helps a lot!
And also, if you don't like the advertisements,
you can always support us on Patreon.
There you can see the video without ads,
in 4K and one week ahead!
Which is also a good deal!
Anyway, that was it for now!
We are gonna finally get started on the roof.
- Ok, so, the structure of the toilet has been completed.
But, the roof has not been covered yet,
and we need to do something...
Because, all the small things and also the rain,
they would slip into the cracks.
So, we need to cover the roof with something.
We are always struggling to find roof options.
Around here, you find corrugated sheets or ceramic roof tiles.
But, that's kind of it!
We'd like to try and find other options of reused materials.
We already made one with recycled plastic that kind of does the job.
And now, we will try an even more local method:
Aluminum cans, that we have been collecting since the beginning of the season.
So, the first step is to clean them.
After that, take the top and bottom of the can off.
For that I made a tool back in Hong Kong, that does the job way faster.
And now, we just cut a straight line the can in the middle of the can.
Now, you get a piece of sheet metal!
So, when we go out to look for examples where people use
aluminum cans to make the roof shingles...
There are different examples.
The most simple way is that people
putting it one over another and using a stapler.
There are some problems, because when you staple it,
you create holes where water could go in...
Also, when there is wind it creates a lot of noise.
The most stable example is when people fold it into this shape
and click on to each other,
That way, the water won't go in from the sides so easily.
But still, from the top the water might 'sneak' through...
So, that's why we come to this solution,
to having each shingle folded on the side and also on the top.
When we put it on to each other, they click on the sides
and on the top, so the water won't go in so easily.
And then, we used this little tap from the can to press it down
without putting any holes on the shingles.
So, I think this will be the direction we are going to go in!
So, to create a shingle from this, to this, it takes a few steps.
The first step is to cut a shape.
Since we have to create a few hundred of these shingles,
and we have to make sure each one of them keeps the similar shape...
We have to create a mold.
There's one shingle!
After measuring the size of the roof,
I noticed that we needed more cans than we can collect in the Kamp.
- What are you doing right now?
I'm making a poster to get cans from the neighbors.
So, I made a small poster and ask for the local cafés
to collect the cans together with us.
Just after some weeks:
We are going to pick up some cans from the neighbors.
There is a really nice café here and the owner,
Elisabeth, has been collecting cans for us!
Let's go and see what's inside!
So, here is our catch!
This is unique one!
We don't see it very often.
Here are the cans.
We already have enough cans for the roof.
We noticed they come in these two sizes usually.
To accommodate them in the design of the roof...
We need to fold them in a way that different sizes of cans
can still interlock with each other, just like that.
You can imagine that in a process
we would create a lot of gaps in between.
We made this kind of prototype
and we're gonna put it under the shower.
We'll see if the water actually come through from the back, so...
I think the results seem to be promising!
OK, I think it's safe to say that the water
doesn't go through for the small one.
Let's go to the big one!
So, the corners have been trimmed.
The next step is folding them halfway with
the mold to mark the folding line.
Here we go!
So, they have been folded halfway.
But, there's still one more step...
We need to fold it all the way back,
just so that they can interlock with each other.
For this part, I think we gather everyone
and ask for some help.
Let's go!
So, here is the roof of the new toilet.
Before we install tiles, we need to put on
these aluminum edges around the roof.
It's kind of for the tiles to grab on to the roof.
Let's do it!
Yes, it's finished! It's done!
- The first thing in the morning and I just woke up!
Amazing!
- You have to record your face Gui right now!
Yeah! Turn the camera around!
After so many people drinking, having so many days
and so much effort: the roof is finally done!
- So, there's the roof!
This is a completely new kind of roof design.
An experiment to try and find more recycled materials to work with.
If you want to download the drawings of the mold,
in order to replicate it, or follow how it will behave over time...
Click the link in the description below,
so you can follow it in the research module!
Now, we need to wait until rain comes,
see how it actually holds up and if you can poop dry.
Sometimes things take time before
you see if a creation works out.
Just like a few years ago, we planted this young peach tree when we arrived here.
- We planted it about 2 and a half to 3 years ago?
We have our trees and bushes, so it's time to start planting.
Last year, it had a few fruits,
but this year was really, really heavy.
It was even falling into the pathway that we have.
About half of the fruits were already eaten by the people,
and the rest is starting to be eaten by the ants.
So, it's time to collect them all,
and put them in a fresh place without the ants.
- You can see the ants are just going into defensive mode.
"Gather everything! It's your last chance!"
- This is the greatest harvest of this tree.
Still quite some juicy peaches to go...
- Alright, so, that was it for this video!
Thanks for watching!
This is actually not a peach...
It's a pear, because the peaches got eaten very fast,
because they were delicious.
But, anyway, if you already want to see the next video,
make sure to support us on Patreon!
You can see it one week ahead,
without advertisements and in 4K.
Or not, and we'll just see you here on YouTube
same time, same channel next week...
Thanks for watching. Bye!